J'ai 81 ans et j'ai près d'un
milliard de citoyens Je suis au pouvoir depuis 62
ans le monarque le plus ancien de l'
histoire depuis mr.  Kareem, vous
voyagerez jusqu'à vous servirez la reine, mais
quoi que vous fassiez, vous ne devez pas regarder sa
majesté, il y a une autre famine en Inde
et nous voyagerons et sommes honnêtes, êtes-vous
vraiment une suppression terriblement déprimante, vous
pourriez dire que vous vous sentez soudainement beaucoup
mieux  comment aimez-vous vos
costumes de bureau les plus proches il y a un grattement
tout ce qui est proclamé gratte
avant peut parler de ce qu'il est
plus long le vert des fruits j'aime une
langue là-bas je fais pousser un ninja
bien je suis l'impératrice des
Indes  mais tu étais censé être en train de mourir
personne ne sait vraiment ce que c'est que d'être
reine mère biologique
tu souris à quoi ça sert
donc c'est ta vie je voudrais mr.  Abdul
pour m'apprendre mais c'est un Indien tu es
Madison et la reine d'Angleterre
j'aurai toute l'aide dont j'ai besoin
tu dois mettre l'ordre de tout
mère tu amènes la monarchie en
crise Premier ministre le registre tu
laisseras tomber ces paysans indiens ou  nous
vous aurons certifié fou et
acariâtre cupide de mauvaise humeur et
attachez désagréablement le pouvoir mais je suis
tout sauf fou
comment osez-vous regarder un ordinateur portable Je suis la
reine d'Angleterre Je suis l'impératrice des Indes
mais le plus important je suis un serviteur de  un
milliard spécifiquement autre bruine sur
ses propres mérites
il au Sénat voit maintenant mon ami
mais aussi heureux que cela pour vous
un cadeau de l'empire indien qu'est-ce
qu'une mangue c'est éteint semble que cette moustache est
éteinte
[Musique]
vous